[Music]
oh
no
whoops gonna be a long day i think this
is one of the best things i've ever made
[Music]
oh this is smoking
oh god i feel like this has to work
it's not a disaster yet no is the
toaster the thing that gets me
i'm feeling pretty apprehensive about
how well the toaster's gonna work but i
have made a plan i'm gonna start with
dessert like i usually do and i'm gonna
try to make elephant ears or
palmiers they're like puff pastry
spirals with cinnamon and sugar you can
make them sweet or savory but i'm gonna
opt for sweet to get started i just need
to roll out my puff pastry and i'm just
gonna trim it nice
so i'm gonna use cinnamon sugar for the
filling
and i'm gonna sprinkle cinnamon on both
sides do you wanna be pretty generous
with this
and you just wanna roll both sides up
so that kind of like curls like an
elephant ear
just trim the sides off
i'm gonna let these chill for a bit so
that they're a little more stable before
i pop them in the tester and i don't
really have a backup plan but we'll deal
with that later
moving on to my next course
[Music]
next up i'm going to work on my
appetizer i'm going to make potato chips
and like a smoked fish dip but first i'm
going to focus on the chips which i'm
gonna try to fry
in the toaster i'm trying to keep the
chips all pretty uniform thin
i'm just gonna add some olive oil
maybe i should start with like one chip
in a bag speaking of inefficiency this
is gonna be very painstaking
high heat let's see how that goes i'll
try another one with like
a few potatoes in it just to see if they
can cook at the same time and on this
one i'll try a lower heat as i'm saying
it i feel like that's a bad choice
and maybe this on four
this feels strange
okay so this potato just ripped and is
cooking far from crispy but
let's pop it back in
it smells vaguely
burnt
okay this potato is broken but you can
see it's starting to get a little brown
they're kind of whizzing
they kind of sound like they've been on
a sheet pan in the oven
this kind of smells burning so
oh god
the outside looks like it's getting
cooked and a bit burnt the inside
you just touch it
still
not crisp while those potatoes are going
i'm going to soak some wooden skewers
and some water to get ready for my next
course whenever you're using wooden
skewers whether it's on the grill in the
oven
in the toaster you want to make sure
that you've soaked them with water first
oh this is smoking oh god okay
it appears that my chip is fully burnt
this chip looks good
it looks fine
it doesn't look great
add a little salt
oh god
so for the dip just gonna make a smoked
fish dip got some creme fraiche lemon
zest gonna add a little lemon juice and
you can kind of just like flake it right
off
yum and some dill salt
a little pepper
so pretty listen if the chips are a fail
the dip which had nothing to do with the
toaster
is a success appetizer is done
[Music]
oh i am not feeling good about this i
have my frozen elephant ears and i just
need to slice them
okay little elephant ear let's hope for
the best
there's a lot of waiting with appliances
like this
does look like it's starting to puff a
tiny tiny bit look at the edge there
maybe if it's just in
like one flat square it has a better
chance of puffing i don't really know
what dessert this is just a
puff pastry square
oh shoot this is burning as i suspected
the outside is burnt the inside is still
raw i just i don't have a backup plan
i've never not completed it
guys this is
it's not going well
these are burnt too
the puff pastry square also doesn't work
is the toaster the thing that gets me
feeling
a tiny bit more optimistic than i was
before i've got a plan i'm gonna try and
make lace cookies and what i'm gonna do
is melt the ingredients in a pan over
the toaster
that's gotta work right and then i'm
going to drop them onto the sheet pan
and
cook them like that i've got white sugar
brown sugar butter and corn syrup a
pinch of salt
toaster on high
if i can pull this off i will be very
impressed so far it looks like a blob
oh okay okay this is this is looking
good wow
i'm gonna add a little bit of vanilla
this looks great it looks like a small
amount of batter but you only use like a
teaspoon per cookie and then they spread
and i'm just going to wrap this to foil
i wonder if i should take the tin foil
off
if i put these in the oven they would
kind of spread into like a perfect
circle but i think because the heat is
uneven you know it's coming out in slots
it's kind of formed these abstract
shapes i wonder if putting the sheet pan
on top
again to create that like oven
environment i would never recommend
doing this at home and i will also never
do this again i feel like my next course
will be a little more successful but at
this point who knows
[Music]
i'll be honest they don't look great
this is not what i envisioned
but
it's better than whatever happened with
the puff pastry so i'm gonna take it as
a win okay moment of truth
they're so wrong is this the worst thing
i've ever made i hope the next course is
more successful
this has been a truly humbling
experience but i feel pretty optimistic
for my last course i'm gonna make shrimp
kebabs
how badly could it go i'm gonna be
pretty simple with the
seasonings all around just some salt
some paprika
some pepper and give it a toss i'm gonna
try with one shrimp first
[Music]
i don't know how dangerous this is it
feels pretty strange though oh but
there's some color on the shrimp it's
starting to get pink feeling better
feeling better wow it looks like it's
almost ready
one shrimp
looks pretty good i'm impressed
i have a sneaking suspicion
that i can do multiple shrimp in the
bags
i mean this is also good to know that it
takes only like one pop to get a shrimp
cool
well the shrimp cooks i'm gonna cut some
vegetables zucchini classic kebab
vegetable got some summer squash
seasonings are very simple here but
honestly
i feel like i'm too busy worrying about
you know if the toaster is gonna work i
mean it's like
totally working
these are great this is definitely the
most efficient thing i've done today i
mean
i'm knocking all the shrimp out in like
one pop
okay i'm gonna get some more bags put my
veggies in there and
we're moving right along
i'm gonna test
each one separately
vegetables are cooking
slowly they're more so steaming but
that's fine
not perfect but there's some hint of
color i feel pretty happy about that
these have a little color too
these are actually
pretty cute
[Music]
toaster shrimp kebabs complete this
looks pretty delicious i'm gonna get my
other courses
and give everything a taste the moment
of truth
this was such an intense day i'm really
happy about the appetizer and main
course like these two look beautiful
okay that's a good looking chip
maybe i should try chip before before
dip
[Music]
oh
oh it's so bad
it just tastes burnt even though it
doesn't look burnt
it tastes burnt like all the way through
maybe the dip is gonna help me
oh
wow
the dip is fantastic but i didn't use a
toaster to make the dip and even though
the dip is so great i can still taste
the burnt chip
through it the taste of these is like
a zero maybe a one these are bad these
are so bad i really think my kebabs look
beautiful but let's see how they taste
it's overcooked for sure if someone made
me this for dinner i wouldn't say
anything but i wouldn't really enjoy it
either
squash is fun
[Music]
oh god
the pepper has that burnt flavor too the
same as the potato although they do not
look burnt and frankly could use quite a
bit more time taste wise i would give
this a three it looks beautiful but this
is not good
and now for my most embarrassing thing
i've ever made my cookies
not great tastes like um just tastes
like burnt sugar and it's kind of like
adhering to my teeth i mean i'd probably
give those like a three also edible
but do you want it
no
[Music]
sorry this is smoking scoop this right
on top this is definitely wrong
this is
definitely wrong
[Music]
after doing some research i've come up
with a plan i'm gonna start with dessert
working backwards as i usually do and
i'm gonna make a chocolate cake waffle
i'm also gonna make some chocolate
whipped cream some roasted cherries and
kind of layer it all together so
hopefully you know looking at it you
wouldn't think well fine okay so to get
started i'm going to add all my dry
ingredients together
i have not been working out in
quarantine or ever you know doing the
old spoon trick to get an accurate
measurement some cocoa powder pinch of
salt salt brings out the sweetness and
some baking powder it's going to give it
that kind of like puffy cakey quality
and i'm just going to whisk this all
together so far things are going very
well got my dry ingredients i'm gonna
move on to the wet ingredients so sugar
is actually a wet ingredient fun fact
and some milk quite a lot of milk i
haven't made waffles in two years see
how this goes some vegetable oil keep it
moist a little bit of vanilla extract
just you know more flavor does anyone
actually measure vanilla extract don't
think i ever have two eggs
wow big shell rookie move this is like
comically inappropriate size
okay
there we go
now
wet ingredients go into the dry
ingredients looks very wet oh god
will this go in a waffle iron it feels
like too wet to do that i think i'm
gonna add a little more flour but maybe
that is the texture of waffles or cake i
don't know i make it a cake to go in a
waffle maker
just want to get this batter really
smooth
really just been sitting on the couch so
this feels like a real workout
okay it looks totally fine i'm gonna put
this to the side i'm gonna start
whipping some cream getting these heated
up so at least like a few things can
happen at once one of them can go
maximum heat and one can go
medium heat
we've been here before but this requires
some whipped cream and as always i don't
have a hand mixer
it's gonna take a while
actually using this small bowl and a big
whisk is going much faster i wanted to
add some chocolate to my whipped cream i
had an idea that if i put some bars of
chocolate in aluminum foil and put it in
the waffle iron that it'll melt okay
this is super hot so
i assume you can put foil in a waffle
iron just gonna go with it over here
also very hot i'm gonna give this a
spray and
i've got a half cup here i think that
looks good just smooth it out
if this is a bust i have a lot more
batter so we're okay this is not like a
traditional black forest trifle cake
whatever you want to call it but
inspired by you know oh there's some
chocolate coming out the top okay yes
it totally works
wow wow wow okay gotta work quickly it's
not a ton of chocolate but let's see how
this goes this is the best idea i've
ever had amazing wow oh shh sorry this
is smoking smoking typical
i'm gonna put waffle master on my resume
this is amazing up next so typically for
a black forest cake you would soak the
cherries in like a dark cherry syrup
with some cherry liqueur i'm not gonna
do that i just thought i could put some
of the cherries like in the waffle iron
to kind of like roast them or get them
softened and maybe get a little more
depth of flavor i'm just gonna put a few
down
actually i'm gonna put them all down i
don't know
it's on really high heat so i think
these are gonna go pretty quickly
meanwhile i kind of think this is done
oh okay the waffle just ripped a little
bit when i was trying to pick it up and
it is not cooked yet so i think i just
need to be patient for a few minutes but
i'm going to put the waffle in here i'm
going to tear it up and then i think i
can start layering my truck ball
oh oh oh the cherries are letting a ton
of juice out but they look great you
know they're kind of like saucy a little
broken down
waffle still looks good
[Music]
it feels cooked through it still has
some good springiness it smells
incredible i'll do a layer in the bottom
no time disguising the waffle i realize
i'm putting like a hot waffle in just
maybe not the best idea and a layer of
this like chocolate whipped cream and
some cherries
those are some syrupy cherries this
looks
so good it is totally unrecognizable
maybe not a good way but that's okay
oh
having a moment to myself
wow honestly a shame that no one else
can have this this is so good and then
some more cherries okay it looks kind of
crazy oh it's dripping down the side oh
god what have i done should i dump the
syrup on it
the answer was no okay i think the
hardest part about this that it kind of
looks like a disaster oh my god it's
kind of like a sticky mess right now but
it also looks pretty good i'm gonna move
on to the next course
my trifle is in the fridge so i'm gonna
move on to my appetizer course i'm gonna
make an okonomiyaki which is like a
japanese savory pancake it's got cabbage
and egg you can also add other
vegetables but i'm gonna keep it pretty
simple i've never made okonomiyaki
before but i really really really love
it it's going to be in the shape of a
waffle but it gets covered with sauce
and bonito flakes and more scallions so
i think it'll look kind of like this
pile of stuff rather than a waffle okay
to get started going back to my flour
good pinch of salt
and my eggs
and i'm just gonna add it right to the
flower
stir it all together this kind of looks
like the beginning of crepes so i'm just
gonna use green cabbage and scallions
for my okonomiyaki filling and i just
want to cut it really thinly so that
it's kind of like more of an even
pancake and you're not like
so i'm upping the eggs taking down the
flour
a lot of salt going from one cup to a
half cup this already feels better just
lighter you know okay cabbage
and i feel confident so i think i will
add some scallions that feels good for
now spray this down so it's ready to go
and again using my hands oh this feels
so much better so i think it's supposed
to be like just more like lightly held
together
don't do that at home
okay
cool i'm gonna clean up and hopefully by
the time i get back this will be ready
okay this one smells right looking way
more right okay i'm gonna cut the rest
of the scallions hopefully this will be
done soon it gets okonomiyaki sauce on
top so i've got some oyster sauce
ketchup and
worcestershire god
stir it all together i mean it has the
right look okay there's some raw eggs
still on the side but it's almost there
so i've got some nori that i'm just
gonna use some scissors to slice up i've
got my okonomiyaki sauce cupid
mayonnaise and bonito flakes so all of
that's going to go right on top just
like cut it into thin little strips it
still feels thick but i wonder if that's
just kind of like inevitable with the
waffle iron shape just getting pressed
up you know to create that like classic
shape so i'm gonna go with it it's fine
if it's terrible i'm the one eating it
okay just like that around this side yes
oh my god okay gorgeous okay i'm gonna
go so you kind of go like back and forth
oh god i'm so sorry to everyone who
actually knows how to make this and the
kiwi mayonnaise
and then bonita flakes dried cured fish
and you just kind of put these on in a
pile on top they're pretty pungent so if
you're not into fish
you might not like them some of these
like little sliced nori and then i'm
just gonna add some scallions i feel
pretty proud of myself because this does
not look like a waffle okonomiyaki done
i'm gonna move on to my last course
so for my last course i'm going to make
black garlic butter rubbed cod with some
grilled scallions i mean i really think
no one's gonna know that this was made
in a waffle iron you know well you all
know but uh it could fool someone so
black garlic is just fermented garlic
and the cloves they're really easy to
peel unlike you know regular garlic they
just get kind of like soft they just
kind of melt away so i'm just going to
get a few cloves and mash them into a
paste and add them to butter easy enough
like how soft they are they just kind of
press right under the pressure you can
put this on roast chicken vegetables i
mean honestly pretty much anything you
could add it to a vinaigrette it looks
like incredible flavor there oh the
butter is not room temperature okay i
think this is nothing that a waffle iron
can't melt so it's probably gonna get
pretty hot but i'm just gonna let it go
for a second grab some scallions i'm
just going to trim the tops of the
scallions i want to leave them whole so
they can kind of be like draped around
the fish and just going to douse them in
some olive oil and i think for these i'm
going to do it on high i'd like to broil
whole scallions so they get like really
just like crispy and i mean almost burnt
so i kind of think the same thing could
happen in the waffle iron these are a
little big for the waffle iron but i
think i can just move them down when
they start to get charred
that looks ridiculous okay back to the
butter oh
you can hear them start to sizzle
i feel very grateful for two waffle
irons right now oh yeah i realize this
doesn't look very appetizing but the
flavor is going to be so good can i add
a little pepper salt
amazing color starting that's a good
start i feel pretty good right now i
mean we'll see how the fish cooks but
everything is working out i feel like
the the result of that okonomiyaki
really like boosted my confidence
there's still some butter chunks here
but actually i'm just gonna let it sit
moving on to the fish
so i've got some beautiful black cod
here this is way too big for waffle iron
so i'm just gonna cut this
and i'm gonna rub the black garlic
butter directly on it again i know this
doesn't look super appealing but the
flavor is what we're after i thought
black cod would be a good fish to use
because it's thinner it's pretty
delicate you don't want it to cook
through so it's not going to have to be
in there for too long i mean i've never
put black cod in a waffle iron so i
really don't know but that's what i
assume i'm just going to add some olive
oil and just wrap it up
this is this is weird okay here we go
these scallions are really sizzling now
oh wow i'm gonna just now move them down
if i was making this on the stove um
maybe five to seven minutes not too long
um you know you want it to just like
flake away with your fork black cut is
so delicate and such like a sweet fish
that you really don't want to overcook
it
oh i forgot i wanted to do a charred
lemon too okay
back with a lemon i thought it'd be nice
to char the lemons just to get you know
a little more flavor okay i think these
are good to take off
and i'm gonna add some salt
actually i mean this is can i serve this
as the meal just plate of scallions
and the lemons just gonna put them right
down i feel like that'll work again the
fish is going i'm just gonna turn it
around so that it cooks evenly i don't
really have a backup plan if this fish
doesn't work so it actually might end up
being just scallions but
we'll see it smells amazing oh it's
because it's leaking out can i just take
a peek
it's
perfect it's like flaking without doing
anything i mean i don't own a waffle
iron but if i did i might be using it to
make fish this is insane okay fish wow
this is so delicate oh my god it might
even break apart
oh my god i mean it might even be
overcooked i'm shocked to say that so
i'm just gonna kind of like arrange the
scallions around and you know for
everyone wondering why i didn't trim
these they're totally edible whenever i
make scallions i leave the roots on wow
okay let's check these lemons i kind of
think because of the shape of the waffle
iron this is like as good as they're
gonna get but there is some color
okay black garlic butter cod with
scallions made in a waffle iron i'm
feeling pretty jazzed
i'm so excited about this i feel really
proud of myself i feel like i've come a
long way i think i'm gonna dig right
into the okonomiyaki looks cooked
it's quite good
it doesn't taste exactly like
okunomiyaki it's a little thicker i
think i could have put a little less
batter in there but the flavor is like
amazing i think you know one out of ten
i'd give this an eight
okay moving on to the black cod the fish
is already flaking apart
it's shocking
this is really really good putting
myself in someone else's shoes i would
never guess this was made in a waffle
iron this is so cool i feel so proud of
myself i love it you know i think the
fish is overcooked by maybe a minute but
it's still really delicate melts in your
mouth 8.5 i'm so sad that i can't share
this food with anyone i have to tell you
i've been waiting for this all day this
is a crazy big bite but i've got some of
the waffle some of the chocolate whipped
cream the cherries
this is amazing the waffle consistency
all teared up like becomes a perfect
vessel for the cream to get soft but
actually still has enough structure the
cherries are just you know they got kind
of roasted they're kind of like falling
apart in your mouth they're delicious
this might be one of my most successful
meals yet really i'm like sorry one more
bite
[Music]
oh
no
this could actually work
whoops gonna be a long day this looks
kind of crazy this is very strange it's
a great idea
see something new every day huh i think
this is one of the best things i've ever
made
i'm still feeling pretty nervous but i
actually have a plan i'm going to start
backwards like i usually do with dessert
i'm going to make chocolate covered
strawberries with a magic shell it
sounds pretty simple but i'm using hair
tools so we'll see how that works out i
had an idea that if i put some chocolate
in a bowl and then put it over the hair
straightener and also use the hair dryer
the chocolate might melt oh god
[Music]
shoot i'm gonna see if just the hair
dryer works
it's gonna be a long day
yes this is gonna work this is gonna
work
starting to melt thank you
i'm gonna add a little bit of coconut
oil that's how it gets that magic shell
this is looking so beautiful
okay i'm gonna grab some strawberries
and
dip them see what happens
luckily these are very small
strawberries
so
wow
i'm shocked impressed proud
i mean
this might like this could actually work
i assume the same thing is gonna work
with white chocolate i don't know why
chin i think i'm just gonna do some like
little decorations so i need less
chocolate
[Music]
i think it should work
polka dotted chocolate covered
strawberries made with a hair dryer
gonna pop these in the fridge
move on to my next course
for my appetizer course i'm gonna make
blini they're like little russian
pancakes that get creme fresh and smoked
salmon sometimes caviar if you're really
fancy and they're usually really small
so i think that'll help me here but i'm
going to try to make them on the hair
straightener
we'll see what happens
got buckwheat flour and
all-purpose flour pinch of salt a little
bit of baking powder and
just whisk this together
for the wet ingredients i need this
butter to be melted so i thought i could
just use the hair dryer again
i'm gonna make the executive decision
that that's enough butter it's like a
slip and slide over here and a little
bit of milk
now wet to the dry
okay well that was pretty easy and i
wonder if i should cover this in tin
foil
this looks kind of crazy it's not super
secure but
it's okay and i've got this little
cookie cutter
which is actually like kind of the size
that you would want lanny to be anyway
and it
barely fits on top so i'm gonna just
spray this cookie cutter down
and then i'm just gonna pour the batter
ah i wonder if i hold this will be
like kind of steam it
this is very strange i don't know what
the quick time on a strainer is if i was
doing this on the stove a minute or two
and then you flip them which i haven't
quite gotten there yet it's bubbling
it's cooking
so crazy
and and you can hear it
kind of sizzling
oh god oh god
okay
okay
i think with this little plate if i just
have four of these that's like the
perfect appetizer for one i think i need
to wrap the hair straightener more
securely in the foil first
and i'm gonna use butter instead of the
canola oil batter
hopefully it's fine
it smells
delicious okay perfect
so i'm just gonna do like
a little bit of creme fraiche
smoked salmon and then any sprig of dill
these are gorgeous i honestly don't
think anyone would know they were made
with a hair strainer
for my last course i'm going to make a
sandwich which sounds kind of basic but
this sandwich is going to have steak and
grilled onions and blue cheese pretty
classic combination
and i'm gonna try to use all three hair
tools
see how it works first i'm gonna start
with my onion drizzle with some olive
oil my idea was that i could just put
the onions like right in between
[Music]
you can hear it already onions and a
curling iron see something new every day
huh
it smells pretty good while the onions
are going i'm gonna move on to my steak
they're definitely getting color on them
it's not quite even i think
letting some of it hang off i thought i
could kind of like smoosh it back under
but i think it all needs to be under the
kind of like clamp of the curling iron
nice
okay
onions they're going just gonna season
the steak with salt and pepper
wow
okay look at that color it's perfect
softened golden brown five tiny onions
straightener is ready
put some olive oil on it try with this
one
the meat is changing color which is
great
looks a little gray these are going to
be mini sandwiches oh there is a tiny
tiny bit of color
[Music]
that is some pretty good color
might be a little overdone but
i wish i could taste it
i don't know how this is going to turn
out
[Music]
they look kind of gray and sad right now
but at least i'll be disguising them in
a sandwich okay my onions and my steak
are done i'm gonna clean this up before
i move on to the bread
so i was thinking that i could cut the
crust off
and i'm gonna butter it on both sides so
that hopefully the bread will get like
extra golden brown a little bit of blue
cheese a few onions the steak
i think it's gonna work like the way
i've envisioned this it's like golden
brown beautiful maybe the blue cheese
gets a tiny bit melty oh no
oh no no no no it just fits oh my god
[Music]
it's definitely
flattening like a panini there's no
color yet it just looks like it's
drenched in butter
[Music]
i spoke too soon it's a great idea
okay it's certainly not what i
envisioned
but it smells amazing i think the flavor
is gonna be insane but it just looks
like
bad
okay so here's the thing
these two look the prettiest but i'm
most excited about eating this
disaster but like
aesthetically wow
first up my little blini with smoked
salmon
you would literally never know
they're amazing
wow
honestly 10 out of 10. that is so good
now for this
the bread was the wrong choice
aesthetically but
flavor wise this is so good i think this
is one of the best things i've ever made
on this show
[Music]
you